we're going behind the scenes of one of
Mindy kaling's Brilliant Creations we're
going to be finding out just how many
things on set are fake what it was like
filming those intimate scenes and all
the Antics the actors get into between
takes we know their common room isn't
really a common room but they don't even
have a TV we have a remote control for a
TV that doesn't exist what are they
supposed to do in between takes pretend
to eat plastic cereal this is where we
cook coffee and cereal which is fake
here we have some lovely little food
that looks real it definitely looks real
enough anyway but apparently before
shooting the prop team does replace the
plastic food with real food to give the
scene a dose of reality which they are
learning is dangerous because when I'm
hungry I eat the prop food the espresso
machine is real though which is probably
why they don't actually use it I can
show you this amazing espresso machine
that we have never used it's one thing
to film an intimate scene with another
actor but it's a completely different
experience to just record the noises of
said c Pauline chalamet found the whole
experience to be incredibly awkward she
cringes as she recounts her experience
saying the worst is when you're an ADR
when you're watching the scene and
they're like we need a bit more moaning
and they're like okay do a few more with
your mouth open that's the epitome of
cringe now let's talk about the filming
aspect of it I was meeting them for the
first time while we were shooting we
didn't have a rehearsal or anything for
Amrit cower one of the most embarrassing
moments for her was trying to film an
elaborate intimate scene with someone
she just met whose name she could not
remember for the life of her it's okay
though because he couldn't remember hers
either we're like hi sorry what's your
name again apparently being on set in
your birthday suit is kind of fun at
least for Pauline chalamet anyway she
says because the show was a comedy and
because the set feels so safe it makes
filling the nude scenes way less awkward
than you'd think safe set plus comedy
makes it so that when you're naked it's
kind of fun she says maybe if the show
were a drama or even a bit more serious
she would feel different but because of
the tone it's always all good Renee Rapp
felt a lot of pressure filming
leighton's coming out scene she didn't
have a great experience coming out when
she was younger and I have now learned
that I actually was like super repressed
she took this experience and used it to
recreate her own coming out story this
was sort of like a very liberating like
Carefree way to come out Renee rap is
down for whatever one of her funniest
days on set was when she was getting a
milk carton repeatedly thrown at her are
you down to get a milk carton thrown at
you I was like yes I am yeah yes I am it
was thrown at her a lot I got the milk
carton thrown at me far too many times
but was so down and we were all dying
laughing she loved the scene but hated
the two percent Mill Charlie Hall really
had to test his acting skills for this
role his character is super passionate
about math and science but in reality he
doesn't have the slightest clue about
any of the lab equipment he's supposed
to be working with we spent a lot of
time in Labs because our characters are
in class together and the entire
experience was so foreign to me I was
trying to suppress anxiety about not
knowing what any of the equipment
actually does he says it would have been
much easier to play a science class
screw-up behind the scenes singing
became a regular habit for the cast lots
of singing lots of acapella we like to
sing
um You Are My Sunshine and around and
most of the time they would just make up
songs on the spot to entertain
themselves in between takes we just sing
things so like it's like oh you're
wearing a blue tie today
did you notice Aaliyah Scott's childhood
pictures on the wall there are actual
moments from her childhood I showed up
and they had so many pictures of me off
the wall and I was like guys we didn't
need to before the show started they
asked her to send pictures from her
childhood but she had no idea they would
be plastered up on her dorm room wall
when she got there so yeah these are all
my friends from home and now they're in
the shower and on the wall which I think
is really sweet this was Aaliyah Chanel
Scott's first TV role ever and she was
terrified she still is sure I have no
clue what I'm doing tell me something
tell me something I can learn clearly
she was doing something right and soon
after she booked Hulu's reboot did you
know Amrit Carr is also a stand-up
comedian when she had down time on set
she would head over to Sherry Shepard's
trailer to practice her routine we did
it again and again every time you were
on set Sherry was one of the first
people ever to see her stand up set
before she took the stage for the first
time we're so not surprised to see the
cast of this hilarious show also has a
ton of fun on set are you as ready for
season three as we are leave us a
comment and tell us what your favorite
behind the scenes moment from season two
was